hi how are you where are you right now
I'm in Israel Sophie how are you doing
I'm good I'm in Berkeley in my apartment
so let me just start integrated by
telling the viewers that guy was a
Berkeley actually two weeks ago and came
for a visit as part of the lattices
program and applications to cryptography
and I guess what happened then there
were increasingly dire warnings of
different restrictions in Israel so I
think most of the Israeli is that
Simon's at the time cut our trip short
and came back to Israel to be in self
quarantine for two weeks and I emerged
from the self quarantine to a more or
less national shut down not quite but
almost and you know we're staying in
place and trying to do our best to be
good citizens and maybe do some research
yeah and I guess a soon after that was
true about other countries and almost
all the foreign visitors left know we
have the people who are domestic mostly
local and all homes switched to a remote
mode but the reason that we're having
this interview is because two days ago I
was looking at my whatsapp account I've
been getting a lot of messages and pops
up announcement from the marker a
newspaper talks about this novel
application that the health service one
of the HMOs in Israel has launched to
predict who would be hurt most by
coronavirus thinking if they became sick
and they say they are using novel
techniques from AI to predict that and
that immediately rung a bell that this
might have been related to some work of
yours on something entirely different
so we're conducting this interview to
kind of hope that you can explain to us
what's the connection from the work that
you've done on algorithmic fairness and
this current news so can you tell us
something about algorithmic fairness
what is algorithms and machine learning
tools are having a larger and larger
impact
our daily lives and on decisions being
made about individuals everything from
health care which is relevant nowadays
to the judicial system loan financial
decisions and you know as computer
scientists we know that these decisions
aren't necessarily fair and we have a
responsibility to really think about the
ethics of these systems and of these
technologies and in particular how they
can affect different groups and
disadvantaged groups is a particular
focus of interests so I would say the
study of fairness is and new people
across many many fields have been
thinking about fairness for millennia
but you know computer science and it's
interaction with fairness is new and we
have a responsibility as computer
scientists to think about these aspects
of technologies that were involved in
and hopefully you know it's
theoreticians and as computer scientists
we can also help mitigate or resolve
some of these issues so when you say the
word fair it seems like a loaded word
and just probably means different things
in different fields and I understand
that even in our own field different
technical definitions come up it's
actually a very interesting debate what
is the right definition so our
definitions equivalent to each other
definitions achievable is there some
sort of a specific angle then your
research mistakes so I would say at a
high level you know my background is I
was a cryptographer and you know what
I'd like to do is first of all when we
talk about fairness and you're right
that it could mean different things to
different people and the first thing we
want to do is to think about the problem
and you know rigorously mathematically
define what it is that we mean by
fairness in a particular setting or
towards a particular goal and what
you're alluding to is that unfortunately
you know unfairness things are the
problem is hard and things are
complicated and they're very context
dependent fairness can mean different
things to in different settings and to
different people
so it ends up being quite a tricky arena
to to think about and to solve and I
think my focus and a lot of the
theoretical communities focus is really
on trying sort of have a menagerie of
definitions try to tackle different
concerns that Kannamma come up different
issues different settings try to find
some common themes and so we can have a
few different flavours of definitions of
fairness and we can study them and we
can talk about you know when are these
definitions achievable when are they in
conflict with each other what are the
resources needed to achieve particular
definitions of fairness what are the
trade-offs sort of try to build a better
picture of the landscape so for example
maybe it would be helpful to ground it
in a few examples a fairness you know
application domains so I know that that
know that we're using algorithms closely
to replace a lot of mechanisms for
decisions existed before and judicial as
you claimed as you alluded to in risk
right for banks and school admissions
and even in medicine maybe there's one
example that you think would be like the
best to kind of explain what would be an
unfair the decision-making process and
how could you make it better so maybe
let's talk about fairness in the context
of machine learning an automated
prediction or usually the setting is
that we have a data set of historical
data and we're trying to learn to
predict future behavior maybe it's
trying to predict who will recidivate if
we let them out on bail maybe we're
trying to predict who is likely to
default on a loan and maybe we're trying
to predict who as the greatest odds of
survival if we give them a certain
medical treatment and there are many
many issues in this setting one serious
issue of course is that the data you're
learning from might have a lot of
historical biases embedded in it and due
to these historical biases what's going
to happen is that the predictor you
learn is going to be biased itself
so it's going at the very least probably
to maintain whatever biases were in the
data and it might even amplify them I
understand so there was a work a
specific work that you are involved in
on multi accuracy I think the name is
vibration and I think it's a joint work
with a few other people and those won't
know if you want to say a word about
about this recent paper
yeah so I said there are lots of
concerns we might have when we're
talking about discrimination a different
concern is you know maybe the data
aren't biased it could still be the case
that the machine learning itself because
it's trying to optimize for some global
loss might ignore some group for example
they might ignore a minority if the
minority sort of looks different from
the general population the machine
learning might optimize for accuracy on
the general population and forget about
the minority so when you say minority is
that the thing that comes to mind is
that there's some historical
discrimination or somebody has been
aware of discrimination I understand
that one of the novelty of your work he
said that's not necessarily the case
there might be groups that we haven't
actually even identified in the past
right so one of the big difficulties
when we're trying to talk about you know
underrepresented groups or groups that
have faced historical discrimination is
we are not always we don't always have
an accurate picture of who the group are
even if we're concerned with a large
demographic group it might be the
discrimination doesn't show up in
aggregate but it really shows up clearly
if you talk about a particular sub
population within that group and so
often we just don't know and that's a
big difficulty faced by a lot of
techniques that just try to look at
things it's sort of the aggregate level
of a single group that we're concerned
about and in this work we took a
different path and the idea is to try to
automatically guarantee that whatever
predictor we're learning it passes
certain sanity tests in terms of its
accuracy on every group that we can
efficiently identify from the data a
particular this is a work dealing with
multi calibration or multi accuracy
joint work with our solar orbit Johnson
Michael Kim and only Rheingold where the
goal was to guarantee that at the very
least the predictor we have has an
expectation when it's sort of predicting
the expected risk of a particular group
it's the expected risk isn't wildly off
so we don't have groups where you know
we see empirically in the data that the
risk is a 0.5 what the predictor is
saying that the risk is 0.9
or we could require something even
stronger and ticular require calibration
I don't want to get into what
calibration is but basically you know
for all the for every group that we can
efficiently identify the members of that
group that gets a a prediction of 0.4
risk 40% of them at the end of the day
should be labeled one and 60% of them
should be labeled zero more or less so
we invented the phrase for all some
groups that you can efficiently identify
so it was an example could you just try
to check that all sub groups of size 100
are treated well or the same as the
general population in whatever your
fairness measure exactly is so the
problem is that you know in modern
machine learning when we're doing what's
called agnostic learning nowadays we
usually have a predictor that's going to
err we're not going to have a perfect
predictor so any predictor we have is
going to have some errors and so you
know requiring that the predictor is
accurate on every group is impossible
because we can always a posteriori we
can talk about the group of people on
which the predictor erred mm-hmm okay
so we're not trying to guarantee you
know we just can't have perfect
predictors and still we want to predict
so we can't try to look at all groups
and instead what we do is we take I
think a very TCS there are two computer
science or complexity theoretic approach
to it and we talk about groups that can
be identified from these particular data
features using bounded computational
resources okay so maybe all of the
groups that can be identified using
polynomial size circuits that would be
great
maybe all the groups that can be
identified using a decision tree of a
certain size or a hyperplane and now
we're talking about a set of a
collection of groups that was defined a
priori and we want to have we want to
satisfy some minimal sanity check for
accuracy on all of them simultaneously I
think you know and I think now thinking
about it you know again
from a little bit of a theory
perspective the flavor of the guarantee
is that no one can efficiently identify
a group that is mistreated where
efficiently identify means from these
particular features within a particular
class of within a particular
computational class for a particular
class of classifiers and you know
mistreated can mean different things in
our work we talk about mistreated we you
know with respect to accuracy so we're
requiring a certain minimal level of
accuracy for all of the groups in terms
of calibration or in terms of the
expectation being more or less where it
should be fun so I understand that even
though I think that probably the first
things that come to mind when somebody
talks about fairness are things like
facilities and more school admissions
and so forth one of the most interesting
arenas is the medical arena where you
really do want to prescribe medicines
that work for the entire population well
but often there are some cases where
it's just not the case you might need
different treatment different medicine
and so forth and I'd spend that some of
your work actually has turned to to this
direction is that correct can you tell
us about it yeah so it's not a new
problem in the medical arena it's a
problem they've been aware of for a long
time but they are dealing with risk
prediction all the time so you know they
try to for example predict
cardiovascular risk your risk of having
a serious cardiovascular event or you
know the risk of certain individual
developing a major osteoporotic fracture
that can be really a life-threatening
event usually for the more elder for the
more elderly so you know medical
professionals have you know since the
middle of the 20th century or earlier
they are dealing with risk prediction
for these things and there are these old
studies these old risk predictors that
are common in you know cardiovascular
medicine and an osteoporotic prediction
of how you actually you know identify a
certain patients risk and then you
intervene for high-risk patients you
have to intervene either with the drugs
or behavioral changes
and these can be serious interventions
and one issue is that you know these
predictors were developed on cohorts of
patients that we're not necessarily
representative of the general population
even at the time and there's certainly
not representative of the general
population nowadays or you know maybe
these were developed in the United
States but they're being used in Israel
which has quite a different population
and so it's a known problem that these
predictors can be far less accurate on
different demographic groups and
specifically I know that in this is a
very data bound right the more data you
have that there are predictions you can
make the more data you have even among
those groups that you're trying to
address the better you can do so I
assume that unless they are the worse
off so in other words what do you do in
the case where you have a lot of data
about the general population but for
some very easy to recognize subgroups
according to your definition there's
just not enough data how do you I guess
that's the challenge how do you address
that that's a very good question and
it's far from a solved question so it's
a good question for us as theoreticians
to think about even when data are
abundant you know these kinds of issues
can come up we often optimize our
machine learning procedures to output
simple classifiers because simple
classifier generalized well but simple
classifiers might ignore an important
sub population so it's a consideration
my experience this particular arena came
from collaboration with the Cloe
Research Institute in Israel which is a
healthcare provider that has over a
million subscribers and has a very
detailed electronic records going back
decades that they are trying to data
mine for clinical insights and you know
they were very concerned about this
issue with their cardiovascular risk
prediction saying so we had a project
applying these you know very theoretical
techniques that were designed
for fairness in order to guarantee
calibration across a wide array of
demographic and socio-economic groups
I guess that probably brings us to the
recent project that has something to do
with the current virus in fact I
remember that a day before you left
Berkeley to go back to Israel two and a
half weeks ago two weeks ago
you got the confocal eat it's asking you
whether possibly you can use your
fairness algorithm to help with
epidemics what you could tell us about
that sure so you know the health care
providers in Israel are trying their
very best to identify who are the people
who are most at risk from complications
should they be infected with a new
corona virus with kovat 19 and the
problem is that data is very very
limited and very hard difficult mmm 19
ANCOVA 19 right there you know what you
know we're talking two weeks ago we're
talking about dozens of patients in
Israel and you know we don't now I think
it's up to somewhere between 2,500 and
3,000 but still even for those patients
we don't have complete data so you know
we don't know maybe they're at risk of
complication you know seven days after
they've been diagnosed or two weeks
after they've been diagnosed so we have
very very limited data still they wanted
to to basically train quickly some sort
of predictor for example so that people
the people who are most at risk would
get a call from their doctor giving some
guidelines on how they should what
precautions they should take so you know
even that level of intervention let
alone you know the level of intervention
you want when someone comes to the
hospital and you know whether they
should be whether they should go and
isolate at home or whether they need to
stay at a hospital because they're at
risk
okay yeah so the
I say where fairness comes in and where
this research comes in I want to qualify
everything I say by the fact that I am a
theoretician this is a theoretical was a
theoretical research project that is now
having an impact on some clinical
diagnostic tools the translation from
the theoretical research to what is
actually being deployed in progress is
far from being one-to-one and I'm not at
liberty to say everything that they're
doing in practice in fact I don't know
everything that they're doing in
practice
so with those qualifiers in place the
idea that the researchers at kalise oh
gosh and I have to give a list of names
earlier but here I'll say the the idea
that my collaborators who I work most
closely with that cleat doctors know I'm
Barda and not a gun had was that they
would take their risk predictor for the
flu for which they have very very
detailed fine-grained data going back
decades and they can predict pretty you
know pretty accurately who has most at
risk for the flu and that's kind of the
virus that they know that is most
closely related to cope at 19 so what
they wanted to do was to start with that
predictor from the flu and kind of tweak
it modify it towards predicting risk for
kovat 19 for which we have very little
data and the only data they could come
up with the only data that they had at
hands were these aggregate statistics
for various groups that were published
in studies coming out of China so their
idea was to take their well trained
predictor for the flu and modify it
using aggregate statistics that were
published in studies coming out of China
so for example they knew the aggregate
risk levels for various age groups which
Amy had mmm from China from China they
had the various aggregate statistics for
people with certain diseases smokers and
now we want to take those and we want to
take them together with our flu
predictor to get something that's
better predictor for kovat 19 and I
won't go into the details I'll just say
kind of what to me the high level
similarity between these two settings
are is in fairness we're talking about
having a predictor that is off for
certain demographic groups that you know
we're interested in protecting and so
the goal of our fairness definition is
to come to come up with something that
is at least an aggregate in terms of its
expectation or its calibration accurate
for all of these different groups okay
and similarly here what they were
wanting to do is to take a well-trained
predictor that is off for these various
populations who might be most at risk
and to move it in an effective way to
these different groups to move it in an
effective way to get good risk
predictions or as good as they could
with the data they had at hand for koba
19 so it's trying to wrap my head around
it and there's a whole bunch of issues
that come up so first of all when you're
talking about prediction you were not
predicting about who's going to get come
in 19 because I saw that data from China
perhaps I'm wrong it's for people
already got to do this right right so
the goal is to predict who is most at
risk of developing serious complications
so given the conditioned on getting the
disease who has most who is most at risk
of getting complications classified
according to age gender history so you
know the the people at khalid research
in israel have very very fine-grained
data with lots and lots of features that
they can use so they can use much more
than simply you know your age and your
gender for predicting the flu what they
don't have is label data for you know
Cobin 19 patients and the goal is to
take this fine-grained data for the flu
together with course data about Kobe 19
and sort of try to come up with
our best efforts predictor with the data
we have in the moment and of course in a
few weeks in a few months we're going to
have unfortunately much more data for
kovat 19 patients and you know then we
can take a different approach so it's
fascinating many two perspectives are
fascinating to me first of all the idea
that something that has to really came
up querying about societal kind of
aspects fairness I think probably the
judicial system I mean schools and
things that are so not related to life
and death at least wasn't clear to begin
with and here we're talking about a very
different scenario a secondly when you
say the word fairness what comes to mind
is not you know necessarily prediction
of outcome prediction of complication so
that's a beautiful transference of these
notions and very you know what comes to
mind again is the usual sentence they
say unintended consequences accepting
this arena of fairness and in general
societal implications of AI or Eri
people talk about unintended
consequences of badly so in other words
you know we invented technology and who
knows what it's going to do to us
in this case you've got invented this
theoretical framework which had some
applications already buddy and I need
tended consequences that he might say
something about this epidemic or
pandemic okay so one thing that comes to
my mind and it's a fantastic especially
a theoretician where you have a notion
and if it's a robust notion of an
interesting notion often finds
applications and understandings so even
though it's fantastic obviously we
prefer not to have this application but
it's very intriguing that seems to be
related and the other thing too - the
speed right because usually you search
you know if an ocean we discuss it and
prove things about it takes a while here
you were supposed to kind of take it
from the very theoretical
two very applied one in what two weeks
one week how quickly did you diss holes
in a barrel oh well I shouldn't say it
was me because I was mostly in Berkeley
and on a plane as this was happening it
was mostly researchers at Khalid
together with graduate students
Daniel Greenfeld and Galliano and
research at the Technion or each elite
yeah things move you know when there's a
pressing need things move at the speed
of light so I think on the one hand as a
theoretician you you have to be careful
and you have to say you don't want to
over promise and you know you can't we
can't invent an entire scientific theory
of the field on the fly within days you
know when there's a pressing societal it
takes time and it takes a big investment
of basic research that I hope there's
going to be ongoing going to build a
community doing these things in theory
and on the other hand when you work on
issues that are just you know that where
there's a pressing societal need you can
have an impact and you know you have
sometimes an impact in unexpected places
so right now at this point people from
medical services which is the HMO
service for alright are getting
announcements whether they're in a
high-risk group depending on this
application is that happening around
yeah I think they sent out it's on the
scale of hundreds of thousands of people
who are being sort of getting various
levels of notification putting in place
besides these announcements so what I
know is mostly what I know from the
article that you also read at the moment
yeah in terms of what they're doing with
it how they're intervening clinically or
thinking of interconnecting clinically I
I don't know at the moment the main
thing the main place where they want to
intervene is in terms of actually
getting a doctor to call the people who
are most at risk and notifying them kind
of explaining that they're at risk and
talking about what we call
Shen's they can take and that can be
quite valuable
you know I think in the future I don't
know if it's going to be this tool or a
different tool that's trained using once
more data is available but no disk and
also this kind of prediction I imagine
what I will also play a role in how sick
people are treated and actually that
kind of brings me to a point that I
think is really interesting and pressing
which is that we know that unfortunately
this pandemic health systems can be
strained to the point where there aren't
enough resources to treat everyone and
decisions have to be made and you know
we started worrying about fairness here
we arrived at kind of a different
application where fairness wasn't really
a concern we just wanted to do a
particular kind of machine learning
tasks with unusual data but bringing it
back to fairness if we think about the
decisions that are now going to be life
or death about who gets treatment and
who doesn't being guided in some way by
an algorithm there are serious concerns
about the algorithm and about the
fairness of the decisions being made
something that I did I was worried
wondering about that at the same time
you are singling out these people and
letting them know what measures to take
and this tool can also be misused
I mean it's question of definition
whether it's a masseuse if at some point
you have us very very scarce resources
and you need to make decisions how to
use them when it's an age-old problem
right it's a very age-old philosophical
if they call question how do you divvy
up these resources and it becomes even
more so if you're going to use an
algorithm to make those determinations
we're not talking anymore about getting
a loan I'm not getting a phone you know
getting accepted to Harvard or not but
we're talking about something much more
important but we're taking it to the
direction that I don't think we should
take it because I doubt that it's going
to be the outcome but it's
it's something that I've seen again and
again when we talk about fairness in
computer science and then we take we
talk to lawyers or we talk to people
from the social sciences and here we are
a reinvented this incredible tool right
we've use mathematics reduce data we can
do really good things and we can improve
the systems and at the same time what
they see is sort of what could happen if
some is the tool got into the wrong
hands or without thinking about it and
down the line the horrible ramifications
and in with this pandemic everything
gets sped up right application see what
can come out of it we see it sort of you
know pass forward but it doesn't have to
get there I think the pandemic is
showing us in many ways glimpses of the
future and of the kind of life-and-death
decisions that computer science systems
will be involved in good way in a good
kind of good way and in a good way and
in a concerning way so I mean I think we
have to hold both aspects of this there
is tremendous good that we can do but
there are also very serious concerns and
perils that we have to think seriously
about and I think the promise of
computer science and especially
theoretical computer science is that you
know we can really examine these kinds
of concerns and trade-offs rigorously
from a mathematical perspective and
sometimes and you know I hope this is
the case more often than not we can say
you know you can have your cake and eat
it too you know we can design in other
arenas we can design protocols where we
compute a joint function of our inputs
but you know nothing more is leaked
about anyone's input we can design
differentially private algorithms that
aggregate statistics without
compromising anyone's individual privacy
and perhaps we can design you know
automated decision making tools that are
you know
mathematically and rigorously fair
whatever fair means in a particular
context so you know maybe we can have
our cake and eat it too maybe we can't
and a scientist you know we can that's
also part of our job to understand where
the real trade-offs are and those can
inform how these tools are used lighter
sign I must say that after hearing about
this tool and even after this interview
the respect that I have toward the kind
of on dirt that I get from my medical
systems and Ghana
tremendously you should get these alerts
you know you should reduce that and the
other I think they must be sending it to
everyone it's the most diluted version
of advice that I could get but what you
are actually describing is something
that might be quite different at least
in this case where they've looked at my
history they've looked at a history of a
lot of other patients and
unsophisticated statistics they have
statistics from other countries and
they've singled out perhaps me or the
good that's similar to me and gave me
advice that I should be paying attention
to and which means that it seems the
team that you're working with is very
high quality team and I wonder who are
they are they doctors are the computer
scientists so this is the Clete Research
Institute which is dedicated to cleaning
clinical insights from their data using
state-of-the-art machine learning
techniques and they're tremendously
impressive so what they've been able to
do just in the span of a few weeks and
not only on this project but on every
project I've worked I've worked with
them they're doctors
data scientists computer scientists
epidemiologists today nowadays the two
people who I work most closely with
doctors is Nam bard and the gun are
medical doctors who also have computer
science degrees and it's a very very
impressive organization and the kinds of
things I see them doing I think are
really a taste of the power of these
computer science tools and what we can
expect in the future
I think that's a tremendous I'm so glad
to see that the impact of work you know
in in theory in the theatre computer
science on algorithmic fairness and your
own work
having making a difference and I just
want to mention I guess to our viewers
that we've had a fairness cluster every
summer in the last two summers where
researchers came guy was there president
I think all summers for many other
people came to Simon's to talk about
different definitions different
algorithms and have a workshop it's
tremendous I hope we have more of these
activities that Simon's in the future
and I think to theoretical computer
scientists or other scientists watching
this there are a lot of challenges in
these fields and a lot of opportunity so
yeah I hope it sparked your interest
that's great thank you and thanks for
staying up this late for the interview
sure Thank You Sophie and stay healthy
and safe you and everyone watching